so it's really cute guys my bleach brows
i'm into it kim kardashian just went
from brunette to platinum blonde to
brunette again
in just a few hours and we're talking
eyebrows people it was a whirlwind
on thursday the keeping up with the
kardashians star took to her instagram
story to post a few behind the scenes
clips from the set of her photo shoot
can you guess what the set vibes are
today yeah that's kim with her hair
pinned back
in a super casual ensemble with her
brows
slathered in bleach i love that
later she posted another video to show
off the platinum blonde outcome
so it's really cute guys my bleach brows
i'm into it can't wait to show you guys
the final look
and as if that transformation wasn't a
big enough shocker
she then posted another story with a
complete look featuring a
super blonde wig bleached brows a smokey
eye
and a pastel nude over lined lip
it becomes
[Music]
is it just me or is she giving off major
lady gaga vibes
i love it anyway that whole look
didn't last long because later that
night she posted
another story where her eyebrows were
back to their original hue
writing i'm back to dark already don't
worry
it was a lot of fun of course this isn't
the first time we've seen kim go blonde
i have always been really fascinated
with
crime true crime the law i'm really
motivated to get to know the law more
back in 2019 the aspiring lawyer dressed
up as elle woods from the hit flick
legally blonde
rocking a pink dress and a sequin bikini
to portray the harvard law student
as you know she's been brainwashed by
the evil stefano
of course kim is currently studying to
become a lawyer herself
and has been focused for the past few
years on helping with criminal justice
reform
my dad always taught me that hard work
is really important and to really commit
to things so
my goal would be in like 10 years to
give up being kim k
and just focus on this and be an
attorney
and fight for so many deserving people
and
earlier this month the 40 year old kkw
beauty founder gave off those
l woods vibes again posting these snaps
soaking up some sun showing off her
curves and studying for law school
all at the same time what like it's hard
even singer casey musgraves took note
sliding into the comments to write quote
elwood's wishes
you